ん
みなさんこんにちは
私は日本ではまだ知られていない
以前分野の専門家です
私はデザイナーですのでその状況
ちょっとおいしいと思っていました
もともと私は
美術大学を卒業して
自動車メーカーに就職しました
自動車のパラ釜山なぁとして
外それー内装の
色のデザインをしたりシートの生地のデザインをしっかりしていました
すごく自動車の仕事は楽しくて
一番良かったのが自分が知っ
今で在職のが同様で見られるということ
どんな人が乗ってるのかなぁとか
なぜこの色々あってくれたんかなーとか
そういうことを想像するとすごく楽しかったです
そんな中で
私は自分のデザインする色や謝罪が
人の心に与える影響の大きさ程度を考えるよりも
実際に自分がモノを買う時に
色や素材が気に入らないとか痛くなくなってしまいます
写真できて印象とデング違うとそれで少しガッカリして顔 now ことがよくあり
ました
それでは逆にお店に行って
買うつもりがないものもすごくいいよだなと思うと衝動買いしたしてしまうことがあり
ます
そうやって自分の気に入った色や素材神の前にあるとすごく幸せな気分になりました
きっと私以外の人もそういう人が多いんじゃないかなと思いますか
ただその当時
まあ今からもう20年近く前になりますがその当時は
デザインの中でいろいろデザインという考え方はまだあまり浸透していませんですか
移動車の世界でも
外装御願いと内装のデザインこれはすごく一生懸命でぐらいするんですけれども
カラーのデザインというのがまだあまり確立していなかったので
まあダイソーや内装の形が決まってから
色を考えればいいんじゃないかと
お化粧レベルな考え方でした
ここに私は少し違和感あって
ただクルマの仕事は楽しかったのでずっと続けようと思っています
ん
そんなある日
ターニングポイントをやっています
入社11年目で自分がやっている仕事が欧州で
cnf デザインと呼ばれていることを知りました
すごく衝撃的でした
デザインの業界の中で色の下剤っていうのはあまり重要に思われてないと考えていたん
ですけれど
ヨーロッパではすごく重要な旋盤本屋として確実あったんだ
それで
さらに専門家もたくさんいると言う
そこに驚いてそのことが忘れられなくなってしまいました
そして結局3年後
会社を辞めて
cmf デザインの専門のデザイン事務所
フィールド得迎春を設立しま
ここで少し cml デザインについてみなさんにご紹介したいと思います
見る人は
カラーフェリアフィニッシ3つの言葉の頭文字を取っています
私たちの身の回りのものを全てにある表面
その表面を構成する3つの8速用教祖なのだよ
カラーとマテリアルというのは皆さんもよくお分かりになると思いますけど
フィニッシュというのが少し分かりにくいと思いますので説明します
死というのは
ちょっと ao
事例で説明しますそうこのいたがーる
黒い板ですね黒くて
プラスティックのインターなります
これも同じ黒いプラスティックのいただきます
俺が何が違うかというとフィニッシュが違います
一つはツルツルで一つはからガラコの表面の仕上げ方が違うだけでこれだけに枝から
詰めます
ちょっと遠いのでわかりにくいかもしれませんけれども桃米の素材のこのような違い
ます
透明のプラスチックこれも元々は等のパイシックなんですけれど
表面にザラザラの仕上げをしただけでこのように白っぽくなります
こうやって新潟が違う仕上げ方で
見え方が変わるのがフィニッシュです
フィニッシュはすごく意匠的にで際のところに大きく影響します
そしてフィニッシュ
ペニスを加工するためにいろいろな技術があり
私は cmf デザインをしながら
その表面の衣装は重要性というのをすごく感じていましたので
それを仕事にして
世の中なものをより良くデザインすできればなと思っていました
しかしっ
この想いがなかなか伝わらないですね
cmn デザインが何であるかということ
それをいろんな人に支えました
海上設立して cm web デザインの専門の会社なので
ca 和風で何の仕事をしたいんですけれども cmf デザインがなくやるかという
ことがとにかく伝わらないんだよ
dmm に関しては言葉の意味としてはおそらく伝わっていると思うんですが描いが
つくとなかなか分かってもらえない
というのもやはり cmn デザインの会社を設立したのが今から9年パイなんですが
ま今から9年前ぐらいですとで剤というとやはり形という風に考えられています
形のないし表面だけのデザインというのがとても分かりにくかったと思う
んですね
それでなかなか理解してもらえずに
まあ7梅部のことは説明するんですけれども分かってもらえないから当然仕事もあり
ません
説明するだけの日々が続いて
はこんなようなイメージでした
私は帳票の見えないしげっ的な壁を登っているんですけれども
どこにいるのかがわからずにしたも見えずでも見える
進んでいるのかもわからない
そんな状態が続きました
ただずっと
説明ばかりしていたんですが少しずつ
まあ具材の仕事もしなければいけないので自分で自主的にいろいろなデザインをしてい
ました
その中で
必要なのが技術です
先ほどもフィニッシュには技術が必要だというふうにお伝えしましたけれども
様々な書く方法があります
素材も無限にいろいろな種類があります
そして技術は日進月歩なので常に情報アップデートしなければいけません
私は技術展に行って技術の情報をアップデートしていました
そこで気がついたのは日本は宝の山でやるということで
素晴らしい技術がたくさんあって
和歌山じゃないか
でもこのたからあまりしなくないんじゃないかなと思いました
もっと多くのデザイナーがこのリースのことを知ることで以前自体が良くなるんじゃ
ねーか
そのように思いました
そこで運営
技術のことをもう少しデザインに知ってもらおうと思いました
ここで一つ技術のサンプルをご紹介します
これはアルミでできたハビか無罪です
外に見えるところには使われないので皆さんも見たことはあまりないかもしれませんが
飛行機のエンジンのフードですとか建築の構造体などに使われています
このある日のハニカムどのように作るかわかりますか
これはですねこの絵にありますようにアルミの薄い板に接着剤をつけて
そして治療が愛に重ねていきます
重ねたものをガード方向にカットしてそれを開くとある日の張りカバンがあるんですね
ここに今まだ開いていないアルミのをカットした状態がありますのでこれを開いてみ
ます
こうやってハリカ部材になりな
これを開いてはにかむにするんですけれどもこの状態だ
芽が育ってないとやはり綺麗でもないし
高機能としてもバラつきが出てしまいますので
follow 形に整えなくてはいけない
心を整えるのに控えたてではなくて人の手で職人さんがきちっと一点一点を整えてい
ます
なのでこのように美しいアルミが葉鹿ノ台ができるんですね
でこれを見たときどうもそうなんですけども私はまず
だめだ美しいなと思いましたので
それを生かせないかなと思って
このようなさ剤を作りました
これはアルミのハニカムに樹脂を流し込んで固めたものなんですけれども
例えば照明の素材にしても綺麗ですし
全部の伝播にしてもいいんじゃないかなとかアツ
アクセサ下にもできるんじゃないかな
いろいろと考えます
そしてこれをですね皆さんが知ってもらおうと思っているんですけれどもそれが
アクセサリーではなくてこの待ってにあるというところで私は備前を止めている
それがちょっとポイントなんですね
この技術のことを知ってもらっていろいろなルートで使ってもらいたいと思っています
ので
それを厚されるしてしまったとたにアクセサリーとしてしか売れなくなってしまう
それなのでわざとこのマテリアルの状態でデザインを上げてい
ちょっと話は変わりますけどこの数字が何だかあります
これは何のものづくり企業の数です
1996年から2014年で大幅に言っています
賃金の安い海外ものづくりが流れたり
日本の景気が悪くて中小企業や町工場がどんどん減っています
でも日本のものづくりは
素晴らしいものがたくさんありますのでこれを何とかしてそう考えてん
技術に cmm デザインを掛け合わせて日本のものづくりは活性ができないか
そのように考えました
技術素材に素材やデザインニップルの日 ur に今お見せしたような技術を
素材化するという活動を始めますか
そしてそれを
1年に1回なんですけれどもデザイナーの上に技術を紹介する展示会
青レスという名前なんですがそして今発表しています
今年で6回目を迎えています
この写真はすべて異なる技術で作られた
サンプルなんですけれども異なる技術に
cmf デザインでの視点を入れて備前サンプルを作って
ってこのようなものをあオフィスで展示して紹介しているんですね
デザイナーがこれを見てインスピレーションおいて新しいものづくりに生かしていく
そのような動きになっています
この写真はあオフィスの模様なんですけれども多くで説明している方がはずロードの
張りカムの技術者の方で
はぎ株の作り方だとか技術的な説明をデザイナーに向けて
ているところです
デザイナーはフラーこういった
技術が話を聞きませんので非常に興味を持って行ってくれます
そして
新しいインスピレーションにつなげていま
こちらの模様もあオフィスなんですけれども
去年で3日間でさあ1300人のデザイナー
ベストか設計士の方が来てくれて
まあ特徴としては技術者の方々が母ならず皆さんいらっしゃって
そのサンプルを見て何かに使いたいとかこんなことはできないかとかっていうのがその
場で相談できるようになってるんですね
その場でとても暑いこう議論が交わされたりとかですね
まあ新しいアイディアがどんどん生まれてきたりとかそういった面白い
場になっていて
その場を私たちは提供するそのように考えています
もともと日本のデザインアート msc 目のデザインを説明したくて
そして日本のモノづくりを活性化したくて
このようなことを考え出してで演じかをやっておりますけれども
まあその広がりというのは少しずつ出てきています
そしてさらにちょっと面白い相乗効果が出てきていまして
まぁこれは普通の場所貸しのもあの美術展とは全然違ってすごく個人パリなんです
けれども小規模ながらかなり密度の濃いイベントになっていますので
出展社の技術者婦さんは同氏がすごく仲良くなるんですね
それで私たちは何も仕掛けてないんですけれども
自然発生的に医術た上司のパパマッチングが起こって新しい素材が生まれたり新しい
技術が生まれたりしています
それとは別にもう一つ相乗効果として
技術メーカー3月の会社の方での現場の空気が大きく変わったというふうによく言われ
ます
モチベーションが上がる生姜ですね
といいますのも今まではお客様の顔が見えずに
技術のリクエストだったりとか性能の北条だとか
コストダウンだとか
そういう要望を聞いてそれに答えるような仕事の仕方を創刊
直接どのように使われるかどうがニーズがあるかというのデザイナーと話してそれを
知ることによってすごくモチベーションが当たるという
いうことです
自分たちで提案型の自主的な仕事ができるようになったというふうに言われます
このような形で思いもよらぬ相乗効果も含めて何か新しい夫婦メイクイーンカー
動きが出てきているのかなというふう
気がします
この写真は浴びずに出店していただいている技術メーカーさんの一部の写真なんです
けれども
とてもいい映画をしてますよね
えっとまこういった
動きの中で私元々あの cm デザインを知ってもらいたくて
そしてようなび日本のモノづくりを活性化したくて何かできないかということでこう
いう逆の考えて展示会をやっているわけなんですけれども
それとは別に分からない分からないと言われていた
この cmf 出ないんですけれども
こういった笑顔に何か繋がってきてるのかな
それっていうのは新しい価値が生まれてきてるのかな
雪がしま
デザイナーが技術をして
素材から湯スピネーションおいてものづくりをしていく
この動きが世界的ではもう当たり前になっています
私はこの feel good クリエーション cn で全部対処初めて
もうは旧ねやっていますけれども今だね先ほどを見せしたような上が見えないような
だけを登っている気持ちです
どこにどうだ弦のかもわかりませんけれども
今日皆さんにひとつお伝えしたいのは
わからないはダーハイと言われたり
理解されないことでもそれは新しいからであって
可能性がないことではないんです
わからないということは次の新しい価値を生み出す
ということだと思っています
どうもありがとうございました